I feel like a comics job at least in my
opinion what I like to do is take the
worst subjects on the planet you know
rape and sexism and racism and
homophobia and anything
I mean AIDS cancer things that people
are legitimately scared of pedophilia
molestation rape and if you can sort of
shine a light and make light of it a
little bit then you can legitimately
help the people who've been a victim of
this what's funny is when people come up
to me and they're it's a black person
and they'll be like you didn't do enough
black jokes Jewish person hey where's
all your Jewish jokes because people
know by making light of it that's how
you include people and that's how you
include your friends we all have those
friends whom we love so much that we
just insult when we see them hey a-hole
hey douchebag you know that means you're
a close friend if you kind of don't like
somebody that much you find you're not
really joking around with them that much
that's why I include everybody on the
planet I don't do that many French jokes
cool not crazy about them but everybody
else is fair game
I adopted the greatest dog in history oh
yeah I named him Parker after Sarah
Jessica Parker no because of the really
astounding resemblance
you know what people like really
disappointed in you right now
let me sit there god damn record
straight SJP
does that look like a dog uh she looks
exactly like a horse to me there's
nothing in comedy that's off-limits
what's off-limits only for me is things
I can't make funny if it's something
that I just don't have the skillset for
I just kind of leave it to the Masters I
remember September 12 2001 there were
already comedians who are highly skilled
making jokes about September 11th and
this was in New York City at the Comedy
Cellar I mean there were guys like Colin
Quinn Nick DiPaolo guys who really felt
and that they could bring humor to the
table with that devastating incident and
they could and I was like I do not have
the skills for that you know what leave
it to them so that's probably been the
one subject area I haven't found a way
to make funny yet or shed light on but
some people do so that's why there could
be no line and comedy other than if you
can't make it funny I was doing probe
work once with a guy and I just kept
calling him all the different gay slurs
because he's very handsome and I always
call a guy gay if he looks like he won't
have sex with me
so I was calling him gay this and that
well he comes up to me after the show
because he had been laughing so hard and
that ends up he goes whoa I think you're
kind of a coward cuz why didn't you make
fun of this instead about me and he
points down that he's in a wheelchair
which I didn't see and it wasn't my
fault cuz the club was dark and his
wheels weren't shiny so he said he goes
you know what figure out that as a comic
you can make fun of all of us even me he
goes even my disability is something you
can make fun of so I was like man this
guy is really open and cool so that's
why I really kind of have no boundaries
with crowd work because I go with that
guy can take it everybody can there's a
website that's literally called www
Sarah Jessica Parker looks like a horse
calm
and they asked her on a talk show if she
ever read it and she went and the host
said come on how many times has you
looked at it and she went to me audience
members are paying for punchlines not
for prose they're not paying to see us
do therapy for ourselves they're paying
to hear us make latest subjects so if I
can't make it funny I'm not gonna make
them sit through it if comedians would
ever start taking seriously the
political correctness that's been
rampant for the last 20 years and it
took Seinfeld to bring it to light in
the last year or so then comedy kind of
would disappear I mean look at louis c.k
look at Jim Norton look at myself look
at people who just bring horrible things
to light and learn how to make light of
it through comedy you know we if we
don't shine a light on it who's going to
but I think it took somebody like
Seinfeld who's a clean guy for him to
say enough are you kidding me so Jerry
welcome to my world that's what I've
been dealing with for 25 years what's
funny about college students is it's not
the college students that are sensitive
it seems that it's the administration
and people afraid to offend the college
minorities I have an audience full of
every age group I have eight nieces and
nephews aged 14 to 25 and when they were
in college I did some benefits at their
colleges the older ones and they never
seemed really ruffled by any of the
stuff I did because I refused to edit so
I don't remember anyone in that age
group ever coming up to me and saying
how dare you I think it's the
administration's who's scared to offend
anyone and I kind of get that it's like
a network being afraid to you know
ruffle any feathers of viewers but it's
just all fear-based if they only saw
that inclusion is better than exclusion
if I include you and if other comics
include you that's a compliment
you